>> Dana: FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP SCORING A
VICTORY THAT HAS THE MEDIA
FUMING.
A JUDGE IN FLORIDA GRANTS TRUMP
A SPECIAL MASTER TO REVIEW THE
RAID ON TRUMP AND MAR-A-LAGO.
SOME IN THE MEDIA ARE NOT TOO
HAPPY AND ARE LASHING OUT AT THE
JUDGE.
>> TRUMP JUDGES DO NOT BELIEVE
IN THE RULE OF LAW.
THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IN
PRESIDENT, THEY DO NOT BELIEVE
IN FACTS, THEY DO NOT BELIEVE IN
LOGIC.
>> IT'S A WILD DECISION.
>> THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROFESSIONAL THING THIS JUDGE
HAS EVER DONE IN HER LIFE AND
YOU WOULD EXPECT IN A GAME.
THIS IS RIDDLED WITH ERRORS AND
SILLINESS.
SPEAK UP BEFORE WE HEAR ANY
COMMENTARY FROM HERE I WANT YOU
TO LISTEN TO ONE MORE.
THIS IS MSNBC HOST, MEDICUS ON
COME WITH AN INTERESTING THEORY.
>> THE REST OF THE WORLD IS
PROBABLY WONDERING WHY HE HASN'T
BEEN PROSECUTED YET.
WHY WE ARE A WEIRD GLOBAL
OUTLIER WHEN IT COMES TO GIVING
FORMER LEADERS SOME KIND OF
BLANKET IMMUNITY FROM
PROSECUTION.
>> Dana: SO THAT'S A ROUND UP
OF WHAT WAS GOING ON.
JUDGE COMEAU WHAT HE THINK ABOUT
THE JUDGE'S DECISION TO ALLOW
FOR A SPECIAL MASTER?
>> Jeanine: I WASN'T SURPRISED
BECAUSE SHE HAD INDICATED SHE
WAS INCLINED TO DO IT.
SHE ASKED THE GOVERNMENT WHAT IS
THE HARM TO A SPECIAL MASTER?
SHE SAID THAT THIS SPECIAL
MASTER, WHICH SHE WILL SELECT AT
THE END OF THE WEEK, BASED UPON
INPUT BY ALL THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, AS WELL AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS,
THIS SPECIAL MASTER WILL HAVE TO
GO THROUGH 11,000 PLUS
DOCUMENTS, THAT PERSON MAY BE
ALONE AND NOT EVEN NECESSARILY
HAVE HIS OWN TEAM OF PEOPLE
THINK THE GOVERNMENT.
BUT WHAT SHE IS BASICALLY SAYING
HERE IS THAT THERE HAS BEEN ON
ENOUGH OF A CALLOUS DISREGARD BY
THE FBI OF THE PRESIDENT, AND
THERE'S A GOOD ARGUMENT FOR THAT
IN TERMS OF THE PFIZER WARNED,
THE RE-UPPING OF THE WARRANT,
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION DELUSION.
SHE SAID I'M NOT GOING TO RELY
ON THE DOJ'S TEAM TO REVIEW
THIS.
AND WE ALREADY KNOW THE DOJ'S
TEAM TOOK ATTORNEY-CLIENT STUFF.
SHE DID SOMETHING REALLY
IMPORTANT.
WHAT SHE SAID WAS IN ADDITION TO
ATTORNEY-CLIENT, I WANT THEM TO
FILTER THROUGH AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYTHING PROTECTED BY
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
THERE ARE ALSO MEDICAL RECORDS
AND TAX RECORDS.
THIS IS BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THE
SEARCH BASED UPON THE WARRANT
ITSELF.
THERE'S ONE MORE THING I WANT TO
SAY.
SHE QUOTES THE UNITED STATES.
I BELIEVE THE SUPREME COURT.
WHERE A FORMER PRESIDENT MUST BE
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY INVOKE
PRESIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
PRIVILEGE FOR COMMUNICATIONS
THAT OCCURRED DURING HIS
PRESIDENCY, EVEN IF THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT DOESN'T SUPPORT THAT.
THAT IS OPPOSITE TO WHAT PEOPLE
LIKE BILL BARR ARE SAYING, YOU
KNOW EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE DOESN'T
APPLY.
IT'S NOT 100% SETTLED, BUT THERE
IS CASE LAW TO THE EFFECT THAT
YOU CAN PROTECT THAT INFORMATION
BEAR THAT'S WHAT SHE'S HOPING
THE SPECIAL MASTER WILL DO.
>> Dana: JESSE, ONE OF THE
LIBERAL COMMENTATORS TALK ABOUT
THE JUDGES DECISION BEING A
BREATHTAKING OVERREACH, WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WERE TALKING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THAT WAS A
BREATHTAKING OVERREACH TO RAID
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> Jesse: THE JUDGE BUT I
DIDN'T CHOP THE WARRANT TO COME
A FAIR AND BALANCED JUDGE PAID
THIS GUY DONATED TO OBAMA, HE'S
AN EPSTEIN LAWYER COME HE'S
RECUSING HIMSELF BECAUSE HE HAS
TRUMPED ARRANGEMENT SYMPTOM.
BUT A FEDERAL JUDGE CONFIRMED BY
THE SENATE ALMOST HALF THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR THIS
JUDGE TO CONFIRM HER, THEY
VOTED -- PRISTINE RECORD.
WHY?
BECAUSE A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT
RAIDED THE HOME OF A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT.
SO SHE SAYS LET'S HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT GUY COME LOOKING
TOWARD THIS WHOLE THING OUT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THAT'S
THE FAIR THING TO DO.
SPECIAL MASTER KIND OF LIKE THE
RING OF THAT.
>> Greg: I WANT TO BE A
SPECIAL MASTER.
YOU'VE BEEN VERY BAD, JESSE, I'M
GOING TO PUNISH YOU.
>> Jesse: I'M INTO THE WHOLE
THING TOO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MEDIA
COMMENTARY AT THIS JUDICIAL
RULING YOU WOULD THINK SHE TOOK
A SHARPIE AND WROTE LET'S GO
BRANDON ON A PIECE OF PAPER AND
WAS LIKE HERE.
NO, IT WAS A VERY THOUGHTFUL
RULING.
>> Dana: HAROLD, IS THERE ANY
NEW ONES HERE?
>> Harold: I AGREE WITH THE
FORMER PROSECUTOR, THIS IS A BIG
WIN FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT WILL LIKELY, I THINK I'M A
DELAY THE INVESTIGATION, WHICH I
DON'T KNOW WHO THAT FAVORS, I'VE
HEARD COMMENTARY IT PROBABLY
FAVORS FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
IT WAS INTERESTING SHE CITED THE
REPUTATION OF THE PRESIDENT, AND
HER CONCERN FOR THE REPUTATION
OF ANY CRIMINAL -- HE OR SHE
WOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
REPUTATION IF THEY WERE
INNOCENT.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A COURT QUITE
GET THAT KIND OF DEFERENCE.
I'M JUST NOT A BELIEVER IN
SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR ANYBODY.
WHEN BILL CLINTON WAS A SITTING
PRESIDENT THEY DEPOSED HIM, KEN
STARTED.
THE IDEA OF SPECIAL TREATMENT IS
NOT SOMETHING I REALLY --
>> Jeanine: THEY DIDN'T BREAK
INTO HIS HOUSE.
>> Geraldo: THEY DIDN'T BREAK
INTO THE COUNTRY CLUB ANYWAY
THEY GOT A COURT-APPROVED ORDER.
THE PRESIDENT STILL -- WHEN I
FIND AMAZING IS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP STILL HAS NOT
EXPLAINED WHY HE DEFIED A
SABINO -- FIRST OF ALL WHAT HE
TOOK THE DOCUMENTS, WHY HE
DEFIED THE SUBPOENA.
AND IF INDEED HE WAS DOING
SOMETHING WITH THE DOCUMENTS.
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE SPECULATING HE
MIGHT'VE BEEN WRITING A BOOK OR
ANYTHING -- THESE ARE LEGITIMATE
THINGS BUT IF I HAD TAKEN
DOCUMENTS I WOULD SAY I DIDN'T
TAKE THE MORE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
THE ONE POSITIVE ABOUT THE
JUDGES DECISION THAT SHE IS
ALLOWING THE DNI INVESTIGATION A
GO FORWARD AROUND THE DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT WAS THERE, TO
ENSURE WE HAVE BEEN COMPROMISED
AND NEW SOURCES ARE COMPROMISED
ANY OTHER COLLECTION EFFORTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE IS GOING TO DO, IF
THEY ARE GOING TO APPEAL OR NOT,
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY A WIN FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SPEWING TO ME TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO YOU.
>> Greg: IF I WAS A SPECIAL
MASTER I WOULD GET THIS DONE IN
AN HOUR BE THE MOST OBVIOUS
EXPLANATION IS THAT WHEN YOU
MOVE OUT, LIKE WHEN YOU BREAK UP
STUFF GETS PUT IN BOXES.
YORKS CALLS AND SAYS YOU TOOK MY
SWEATSHIRT, MIGHT BE YOU, YOU
HAVE MY FAVORITE WINE GLASSES.
YOU GO NO I DIDN'T.
SHE GOES YES I DO BECAUSE I KNOW
THEY ARE MISSING.
YOU TOOK YOUR WINE GLASSES AND
THEN YOU GO AND YOU FIND OUT
THAT MAYBE YOU DIDN'T KNOW THEY
ARE BROKEN AND YOU DON'T WANT TO
SAY ANYTHING.
THIS IS MORE ABOUT DIVIDING
STUFF UP, RIGHT?
FIGURING OUT WHAT BELONGS -- BUT
EVEN MORE YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
REMINDS ME OF?
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU WATCH YOUR
FAVORITE SITCOM OR DRAMA THERE'S
LIKE THREE STORY LINES AND THERE
IS ALWAYS ONE YOU HATE BECAUSE
LIKE IN 24 THEY ALWAYS SAID MAY
BE THE SECRETARY HAS AN
INTERESTING LIFE.
NO SHE DOESN'T.
OR IN FRANCE WHEN PHOEBE'S
BROTHER SHOWS UP.
LIKE WHY DO WE EVEN HAVE PHOEBE
ON THE SHOW?
THESE TANGENTS ARE NOT THE MAIN
STORY ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN
AMERICA.
THIS IS WHAT IN CABLE NEWS IS
LIKE A TERTIARY NARRATIVE THAT
TAKES YOU OUT SOMEWHERE ELSE,
THEN DROP YOU OFF THERE AND DOES
IT AGAIN WHEN THE STORY GOES
AWAY.
DOESN'T BOTHER TO DRIVE YOU
BACK.
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS A
MILLION TIMES.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
IT'S A THING LIKE YOU LISTEN TO
IT GO WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
WERE TALKING ABOUT PAPERS.
SPEED YOUR BEST TONGUE LOVES
TSONGA.
SPEED THROUGH THE ONE THAT
SAMPLES VAN HALE